Gary from looking you up online I know
about big thing for you is not accepting
the word now and and it thank goodness
it seems like a lot of things have come
your way by you continuing to push
forward when should someone actually
accept that word is your is there a
normal time what's define our terms i'm
not sure that one should ever accept the
word no III really mean that it's in I I
once gave a talk the title of which was
no is just a conversation starter and
that's really what I believe it to be
when someone says no to me I haven't
done my job it's a clue I should tell a
more persuasive story take a deeper cut
not gone more drawers there's something
I'm not doing to get the yes and they're
helping you by saying you're not there
yet that's exactly how I've you know in
the film industry your life is all about
know you get knows yeah I'm not telling
anyone anything they don't know they've
all experienced this we all experience
at any times it feels very harsh and
personal and and defeating but i really
don't i don't want to waste my time
feeling blue about people not lining up
behind me it just every every time i
hear and know it just incites me to push
harder and be better and and speak more
crisply and authentically so you can't
say no if I can be undeniable that's my
job that's all of our job is is to tell
people who we really are why we really
want what we want it's not just a script
for god sakes this is a story that needs
to be told I'm the only one who can do
it this is why this is the team I've
assembled whatever it is so and my gosh
for every film that I've gotten produced
there are so many dead projects on the
floor that ultimately did die but if I
took no for an answer I never produce a
film we've always heard that a hallmark
of a great entrepreneur is being
irritated by the fact that someone would
tell
they can't do something because it
lights a fire in them is there a way to
do it without that negative sort of oh
I'll show them or maybe that's a good
thing I don't think it's negative um I'm
a very stubborn individual and I used to
think that there were there were traits
that i always thought and that could be
negative but it's not a great friend of
mine a brilliant businessman long ago
very successful taught me that you need
your PhD pigheaded determination right
and it's true well there's a balance you
know because they're there can be if if
you're driven that way I mean you
shouldn't want to do a thing just to
make other people wrong you should want
to do it because it's that important to
you you do have to listen you have to
understand the difference between
valuable feedback or critique and
someone who's just not getting the
vision and if you get if you get yeah I
get a lot of knows where I don't hear
the no but I do here oh my god that was
a great piece of insight that was a
great bit of advice or they so totally
didn't see what I was getting at here I
better tweak that piece so yeah there's
a lot of learning in there but i don't i
don't think you stay stubborn just to be
stubborn i think it's because you really
believe in something and there are
enough people who also see what you see
that you're not just dreaming
you